and we uh laughs happy matriarch day and
salutes all the mothers in the realm
welcome to the iron Lords podcast and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 110 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back in the realm on the
Lord's Day no special guest today for
just the laws the oh jeez the classics
so it's only right we bring the four
horsemen of gaming table my brother from
another mother the difficult game of the
actually looking forward to today have
you been playing on the switch plate it
was going on forgot to pay the two
dollars to purchase that out to the
Lords the Emperor is here amongst the
Lords thank you brother
much appreciated on the matriarchs day
in a [ __ ] actually we got was a mojo
mojo he went that matriarch shout out
today cities all
man with mom and daddy raised his sons
alone when they were very little from
one in three yeah you get that shout out
bro anywhere by continue let's talk
about that portability seven unless you
played in the in the fast mode that game
running like 15 frames a second how is
the switch can't even run a 15 year old
game like booth no there's like a boost
mode that it will play the game three
times as fast but only what is that only
in dock motive does that board of a
woman oh my god is dock and portable moe
acting like you guys beyond your dock
like that I'm asking the question I mean
he did say I don't understand you said
they got a boost mode and you have said
that they got a boost mode because
without the boost mode is like it's not
when you're playing where the game was
actually 15 frames a second when it came
out I it runs way better on my PC then
it doesn't see where you go yet yeah if
it's up on my youtube channel game you
got it
there you go they catch that you are
actually really enjoyed that game doubt
no doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord so Lord lives with
a single player offline selfish
experience and also the sastra Damas mr.
offline profile Illuminati and lore
patreon of the iron bank my man Lord
sovereign how you doing sir I'm good man
what's going on with Java I know man
listen I I just got to listen to the
actual episode this morning
that's how folded my life is big
shout-out to Lord angel Ebola man I
slowly it's my duty I bought some
caveats who mentioned it to me is that
you gonna love this new way to listen to
it and it dude
you had me when you said Rambo Master
System ever Oh
oh that's my heart dude I first gave my
god for master system besides you don't
hang on Safari
but do to me that games always been
better than Ikari warriors cheap it is
cheap as hell link Rambo free with Rambo
love that game so shout out to Laura
Ainslie Bowden is he going to e3 so
hopefully if you really agree yeah we
definitely all go look at with whoa link
up at e3 yeah I haven't played much of
anything at all I actually the only
thing I got to do was I got the arcade
ninja gaiden for the for this week
picked it up you realize how like
simplistic that game was like back in
the day I mean again it's a quarter
muncher so he's supposed to just like
you're gonna die million times but it's
really not a lot to it
I don't think when it comes to the home
versions I understand why people really
love those home versions because they
they really gave you the ninja
experience and home we also we also got
a defend arcade for moms for real that
term homeboys couldn't handle the way it
looks anyway definitely not but I agree
the whole ones ended up being the better
games because they actually have more
depth to them here without man that was
I have not played a damn thing together
leapfrog no doubt and of course you have
the Incredible Hulk
aka the XS gamer oh the Lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement Oh beloved
I'm Noah fantastic you'll shout out to
the PVC last night for having me Jared
her versus j-roc Williams ain't no fun
ah Haman is deleted the 50/50 fight yeah
boy you don't know if your boy going in
and get dusted off that night is
physically fight time I love that the
competitiveness of it I was supposed to
a combat talk yesterday but I am in full
promo mode I'm promoting
two new things for ALP going forward
with III will full steam ahead
so um like I'm really in the bushes
right now digging in my bag getting
stuff ready getting stuff together
so you know we're gonna premiere uh
block brothers you understand what that
is when it comes your way and then
you're gonna understand what IOP versus
the world is the world you guys are in
trouble yeah yeah yeah so if you think
your skills is like that you don't
understand what a debut like I know the
tests show chin the need in the segments
there but um slam yeah so Jarrod heard
versus Williams right and that was for
the super Walter wait uh title the WBA
and IBF unified title I'm gonna tell you
you brown one it was on all right Jared
heard was the champion he was fighting
in his hometown we all know the hometown
curse and garden there we j-roc Jay rock
solid all right here we got beat by the
child Oh Bravo I got an album out go
technically you should come out to all J
rock songs that's what I would but um
King I'm supportive but definitely oh uh
J Rock one Oh J Rock went in there and
dusted off the champ it would but it was
a hotly contested fight and round
could've went either way and I suggest
y'all go back and check out the
highlights I'm going to tell you that
was a definite barn burner well I've
been playing destiny I've been so hard
on destiny pulls whoa I'll bring crime
oh I got that already and I got it with
the catalyst she's like wait I got it I
got I got you I got you me the thumbs
the work pose million but i'ma tell you
something
I'm with The Drifter on this right you
throw that whole C gambit gambit Prime
and what was that other um um but of
course reckoning but you got it yep okay
so if y'all walked away from destiny and
I know it's gonna be mad hello destiny
shut up know that reckoning with the
squad squad and the intensity and then
you got to build the bridge and you get
to the job you do level two yeah one
first right harder hello Bo na dead
level two we're going up to the bridge
the epic struggle to get up the hill is
in effect then when you get up the hill
you're gonna fight that boss am I gonna
tell you it is he's definitely somebody
I want to see um I want to do tier 3
this week but I got all my calls I got
the Reaper clothes um I got to collect
the clothes and I'm working on this
century clothes right now real quick you
say Oh stinger from nlgi Lord salute
jumping on real quick before I head to
my mom's house first from others days
without my dad she needs us today I had
to say salute and leave that like that's
what's up
lowest thing thank you brother much
appreciated thank you bro you should um
yeah so listen I'm telling right now
that's what I've been on right now try
to get back on to division I couldn't
that I download that whack game on
that's stupid Daisy oh yeah you ain't
you ain't like it says oh that well was
he is straight crap shout out to deal or
forgetting you get this crap we've been
under the bus for World War Z hot
garbage like the sad part is this right
I was trying to tell monkey don't buy it
I don't get a chance to tell them
alright
and that somebody told me to be like the
day after yeah monkey was the world's I
said no so
hee-hee-hee legit so monkey don't play
monkey put his money down
he's I get my man's opinion I'm gonna be
up in it no oh this is I said you know
what you got it let's play cuz I'm gonna
call Microsoft and fraud it intense in
the back what I did so much fraud with
Microsoft I'm trying to keep my fraud
slate clean
I wanna do a month right without any
fraud and right so we taught we started
up the game it was so awesome in Chinese
garbage all oh just now I may not even
graphically is beautiful if you want to
be a left for dead dude right I'm a left
for dead no I'm a junkie for left 4 dead
1 & 2 right on my oh my god this game is
so left for dead wannabe but it's
missing like some source is something is
missing I have no idea what it is but
it's like he's like a shout out to swoop
the 108 dragon TV said what's good fam
at work but I'm here that's my man happy
for 10 shutout uh 108 dragon TV aka
lemme Thea's right-handed Zeus yeah I'm
a senior hold government and I hit you
back you wake me up in the morning I
looked at my phone so I say yeah I
talked to him later so when I got to the
greatest YouTube glad to have you being
a part of my Sunday ritual slow brother
you know we gonna get you
we need facts Oh Oh little co-op
experience and the gaming ninja himself
Lords get that out you know teespring
y'all that's it of course the shinobi
Lord kognito spread narrowness and aroma
to ILP not telling what you want to hear
but what you need to hear just like King
I've been getting that destiny to on
outbreak prime working with sinister cuz
I got to do that cheese too I got I had
to give you more - I'm working on a
bronze been a crazy week we're not doing
right now five minutes I do what you got
to do you don't mean so I'm gonna get up
in that and then I'm obviously been
rocking that MK 11 on this switch still
getting my dis lon yes so I've been
doing that and I'll shout out to a kebab
suit for put me on to the UH ninja gate
in the arcade version and himself
I'll put me on so that was what's up and
on yeah I'm not so a little bit of UFC
last night so did you see it yeah I did
it at least at least the last couple of
fights definitely a mess we gotta do
some Western please shoutouts really
quick on your way out
this may like you know how I feel about
it
anything I beat up is the leg again
the leg again and they do for the young
boy the young boy was legit
inside leg kicks it wasn't yeah it was
yeah Wow
crazy but what it is you know what it is
King it's like when you get older
and like but before you weave out of
that you check the kit you like slow and
flat foot it now yeah he's awesome check
any anything so he's trying to do this
like you a bother me you a hurt me like
you know I'm saying kata until they
really sink they don't and me he knocked
me right
yes PSD from all that stuff to when he
sees a kick like that he remembers all
that pain he was third and he he when he
questions himself Knapton - yeah
when your legs naps in - that'll do it -
you know that one of the worst breaks
I've ever seen them all right we'll
check the so sad when you know they're
[ __ ] for Chang know like it did I
mean what's his money situation that
he's continuing to fight
Brazil I don't know what his ratio I
don't I don't think he's fighting for a
check I think he just enjoys doing it I
mean you got to think for like what ten
years he couldn't fight who he wanted to
he was the champion like he pretty much
picks who he fights now it's like I
didn't like before the fight he was
already trying to go she ate another
like multi-year contract some his group
some some seemed off at I don't know yes
because it's like he really don't is
nothing less to prove you know I'm
saying like you just was in a while I
mean there's plenty of fires that fight
way past their prime they broke Oh
Drago dragon disrespectful Holyfield the
UFC safety all those get all worked like
yeah boy again turn to the Geritol UFC
yesterday he pulled it um a Nate Diaz
like an 80s ight now he came off the
milk carton and he talked about hating
somebody young and I'm like dude dude
you you six years past a situation you
really supposed to be fighting people in
your age bracket you should not be
looking down the street at young dudes
listen in the music you should be
fighting wheelchair
okay did you see the BJ fight because
identity what does that look like Omega
roughed up like it's just like why you
doing this - like who's in the kid like
we're saying like family you don't got
it no more like I'm blaming Damon yeah I
don't yeah I came a little bit because
there's no way he should begin signed up
for any type look but he shouldn't be in
UFC anymore put it in its right woods
you know Shane or whatever I think I
think what happened is when I sign that
big deal for that money and they want to
recoup those names that they have there
their user now now they using people
names right isn't there's no longer
their skill base and stuff like that is
they named hoping he still got that
flash because I see what was that Chael
Sonnen yeah I seen Jo Sun is signed up
for another fight and I'm like who is
booking this old dude like who was
booking this he gets washed every time
he fights and I'm like what is going is
literally his little yeah but at that
point like you said like go to Bellator
that's what those boats oh but that was
that and then obviously we we had to
main event I let you touch that myself I
don't know yeah we had the return of dog
Rose namajunas as Jessica entourage
who's she's had a few shots at the title
before and come up short um I'll be
honest man like I I don't know I know
Rose after that this L she she sort of
talked like she wanted it she was
walking away like the title was a burden
but in the ring apart from the actual
knockout and how it went down you know
me right she she dominated on drives
like you it was obvious that she is
leagues better than undraw standing on
the ground was powerful she just managed
to pick her up and she dropped her on
the head and she got knocked out and
that's how she won but Rose was gonna
run right through her yet you like
that's a killer yeah baseless she is
she's better and she's better than she's
ever been
and she just I mean on draws his strong
she picked her up she did it twice the
first time Rose held down to the arm and
damn near got an armbar on and once the
money went to the ground the second time
what happened was anand raj was smart
she put the head over to the other side
so rose rather than let go of the arm
she held on to it and a Drossos dropped
on the head and knocked her out she did
the uh she she did the Matt Hughes
Carlos Newton died boom on her head on
her head exactly so but beyond that I
mean roles would have run right through
her to be honest like in terms of the
standard game everything so I don't know
if she's still not a hundred percent
like other than that role Rose is not
doing on late with the ball here right
no Rose is the one he's the one with the
boy ed yeah Rose and Raja strong but
like Rose had her on the ground Rose had
her in terms of the stand-up like she
obviously better just piece on her up
with the one he's the box it was like
everything harder to fight Rose who's
dominating it's just yeah well she for
that on ball and then she you know this
girl's strong and this girl's really
even that first time she lifted her up
like Rose held on to the arm and she she
damn near had in an armbar on when she
dropped it down so she she even knew
what she was doing when she got she was
in a defensive position you know this is
this time around this one about fighting
I'm watching right now because I didn't
know my girl got knocked out cold
you could be women and if you do some
wild night hey make it to the head this
is why nothing's nothing better than
mano y mano
there's nothing better than me versus
you your squad can't help you get
punched and look around like geez help
me please
a man died was it I mean I don't know
she may not be a hundred percent she was
talking about baby retiring like I don't
know she you know she was out for quite
some time injured so we'll see but it'd
be sad if she's done because we got but
we gonna get into Coppola you want to
get into this so I'm gonna get into this
uh let's pay these buildings bill get
into the poll it's the Maya big talk I'm
thank you no apologies for the week of
tardiness but you know so let me go get
into these thank yous for all our
patrons which are numbering I think
number in twenty two twenty three so
that number steadily increasing so thank
you guys the word is being spread right
so our first patron this is its full
name no but there's no is nothing this I
have to use it there we go sniffing
people out wait I believe this is meds
though I believe it's an issue JM yes it
is shout out and shout out to a good
friend forever Patriot Lord whiskey
himself always always always and then of
course the Lords of the slow-mo black /
black not black slap back slow-mo back
slap with them and then we have Lord
Hakeem and PC thank you so much for the
support brother for the support well
appreciation and of course Lord Nick
Nick Tendo direct homie that's been
Dolores thank you so much thank you and
of course Lord fastback 67-68 and og in
the building in the building in the
building X's followed by Lord Stitch 66
69 you know not oh my snitch
followed by Lord by a bond o brother
brother and then my a man with the best
arm B name ever Lord sincere King in the
building of course of course family and
of course gaming forte shoutout to you
my brother in attack Oh
what say you already know and of course
followed by Lord undead and we have Lord
Q accept masters yeah yeah I'm telling
you man I have to do a ticker-tape at
the bottom of the other appreciate the
support us
absolutely man and of course the Lord of
back compat and ex cloud Lord bills
still well right bill in the beginning
thank you sir followed by Lord monkey
punch the original pay my first vote
first in the chest I would always I know
you have some people trying to challenge
for the crown man I know
Lugo gotta be in there like 4:00 in the
morning cuz people when they try that
trying to beat him to it this morning I
saw these first mm-hmm followed by Lord
Sammy Prescott thank you for the loop
and of course followed by family and
thank you for fulfilling in last week my
brother always a pleasure to have you on
the show lo j Fonz
she follows a rally damn I'm gonna jump
up on the walls that I cast slope
Fonzarelli no doubt followed by the king
of the stream team Lord snout oh brother
thank you so much better over lazy to
game stream team we have family from the
cradle to the grave Lord umber himself
loaded pixels kobera and of course Lord
cat daddy fat stacks brother
I can't mask you in a row
he's not fat today cause we gonna roll
didn't cry yeah I am followed by his
second week as part of the patron our
Lord Tao Tazo Ichi oh yeah second week
you mean the second month you're right
you're right we started take this money
every month
this is weakening for the islands we
followed by Lord Johanns lvj gasps soon
as he in the chat today and of course
always last but never least Lord death
singer himself it's calm take what that
world of tanks and world of warships or
whatever we're not allowed to bring that
game up ever but I understand what my
brother has like over 40 days in it or
something like so when when I see you
playing that is your brother bled him I
want you to call your eyes out Lord for
taking me what are you doing playing is
world auto ships or something like that
and then you can do that it's not that
if my xbox is signed in on my PC agrees
that it's playing it and they say I
could be playing something on my xbox
and it will say that he's besmirch in
your fine name you know by playing the
game get to these giveaways so let's get
into this a $10 gift card giveaway game
because you need a machine it goes
[Music]
if you do a super chat at the end of
super cab
say what Lord you want to read it it's
like you put a quarter in his back so
the winner of the $10 gift card giveaway
is Lord Tao this is not any no big thing
somebody threw the thumbs down away oh
really
I was about to pick up the person who
came on I like right at the start the
show gave us the two thumbs down now
fantastic I know what is another one
comes down the pre-emptive thumbs - all
right so Lord Zhao I'll get you I'll get
you in the DMS or in the email and we'll
[Applause]
the winner about $20 gift card giveaway
is Lord vagabond oh I don't think so
well yeah you know what I think so but I
use the government before so yeah he did
they move it shut out I'll get you that
information later and now to our this so
now our teespring giveaway for the month
of the realm yeah oh by the way have you
gotten you know they take of our
teespring
QX 7 masters
several matches and all our winners once
again thank you guys for all of your
support month in and month out I can say
that numbers been steadily increasing so
we really appreciate the support and you
know we're always gonna be here we're
gonna try to give you the best content
that we possibly can so thank you so
much salute to the realm
appreciate y'all we love to support like
like soft said this is really cool to
see it's fun to give back every now and
then what's up
so let's get to this poll all right last
week poll results are in and the people
have spoken to the question with the
announcement of the epic store acquiring
psionics and possibility of Rockley
being removed from steam new purchase
only at a later date and your opinion is
this move anti-consumer by epic towards
gamers the winner at 44% in a razor
close three-way ILP vote is the no stop
crying development its revenue and you
can still play rocket League on steam
and epic store group coming in at a
close second 43% when it was 44 seconds
43 was that I don't care it's so epic
four three two of my favorite exclusive
it in last place at only 13% was there
yes forcing temporary exclusives on an
inferior platform last minute is shady
group thanks to all the lords who
participated in last week's poll Lord
attic king of the epic storm or opinion
of this all I have to say is regards
with the poise go at the story Oh a game
there is a coming out exclusive for the
epic store I'm disappointed we get into
these table are you know we all knew
Isle people at the end but uh Laura
speaking both Lord added that loss off
cuz both of you kind of had
have a topics that mesh with each other
so our Lord I bet you go soft do you
want to start off state of play and then
yeah and it was segue into all right so
uh yeah this past week I believe it was
um Sony had their second state of play
uh Nintendo Direct SK video presentation
and I mean I if there wasn't much to it
per se but it was an improvement over
the first one and they talked a little
bit about a few things first thing was
that it was the expansion for a monster
hunter world the ice-born expansion so
uh but that's cool and I don't know that
was here really big monster hunter fans
but I'm sure they're plenty people
adding did like four days like not a fan
of the game now she was trying to get it
on I was second thing they talked about
none of this order this new sort of what
the heck is it call when you have the
two versus where you know the one versus
three or something like yeah yeah the
round the evolved flash for the
thirteenth type gameplay it's the same
people made yeah so it's called predator
hunting ground
oh the premise the premise is cool it's
just a matter of anybody who play Friday
the 13th the premise was cool some of
the gameplay stuff was cool but it was
just a kind of a big buggy mess look
like a straight ripoff of the Ghost
Recon wildlands with the predator mode
yeah
had that ripple for sir I thought
actually I thought it was Ghost Recon
when I first saw straight ripoff is good
to you so the next thing is this small
sort of multiplayer uh I don't know I
was kind of like action game with
different characters it looks kind of
like Minecraft and it yeah it has it has
like different characters that has the
kid from Bastion and has the protagonist
from guacamelee in it so that doesn't
you know whatever it kind of looks like
a Vita game which is we put it would be
to be a dead um then they had this other
game called away which seems like it's
sort of like a anybody's ever played
Tokyo jungle it's kind of this weird you
saw about the wounded lemur exactly
morale crap crap so yeah you could tell
they don't have a whole whole lot to
talk about
the thing the medieval up remake which
does not look like a remake it looks
like a straight up laughter and a bad
woman that bad
the framerate was not looking where it
needed to be let me guess you gotta be
on the switch this is a play out so my
wing we add that right there because it
looked like the state of desperation
that's what exactly like to me I'm
telling you how it is you're throwing
that final fantasy before square get a
chance to show it on stage and look like
you upset that square took your booth
because square got your booth so you
want to preempt square because you ain't
gonna show it on your stage you ain't on
stage but it was funny over there what
that final fantasy is on Xbox too so
what you sorta for Oh
[Applause]
don't you show it for what show keep
showing a lemur jumping off the leader
that was basically it
um and and it ended off with the the
small return to gameplay for the Final
Fantasy 7 remake and that's what they
ended on so we'll save the details of
that for attic but like overall again it
was an improvement over the first one
but like you know like others like
Microsoft show of this ilk
it isn't doesn't really you know move
the meter too much just showing stuff
that is not big enough to be shown on
the stage somewhere or in a big event
yeah so and again you know that they're
big stuff they're not really gonna be
talking about so you know they're gonna
push this stuff forward and let me know
there's something there although I'm
gonna tell you guys right now I just
okay I cannot I swear I think was that
the last of us is coming out in June
funny you say that cuz I got some stuff
to talk about
I'm telling you right now something
tells me they in the middle of the
Microsoft press conference yeah me you
on that same type of time will talk
about you'll be good to see so many show
I can't wait to get to that but um jump
in man I mean look what so we'll just
show gray it wasn't that great you mean
for the most part but I like the format
I'm now tell you this I like the formula
yeah Rex dad they got the female you
know doing the voice this reminds me of
the Nintendo Direct Mouser you know no
fluff note or just games get in get out
you know what games all that interested
in me not per se but the I walls I can't
front that a mosque hunter that the UM
the ice point it look good and I'm
saying getting hurt isn't that kind
that's multiplied right that's coming
everybody you know say I think they come
in on September 6 so that's kind of
close to Borderlands I wants the Iraq
war lands right now even destiny players
shook like Israel so I wanted everybody
in that September we're gonna see what's
going on on predator hunting grounds it
looked cool you know Sam I'm with I'm
with King I thought it was gonna be like
a Ghost Recon or some type of new
so-called game um I wasn't but you know
it looks interesting you know for that
crowd and then obviously we gonna we
gonna leave final fantasy for addict
he's up
look what's great you know was anything
I'm really per say interesting and you
know thing but I do like the format
quick what was it about 15 minutes tops
baby yeah it was it was very short 2.0 I
ain't gotta see nothing else that's it
one moment is all you want is for them
to continually improve you know I'm
saying show that but I will say this and
I know what Kings gonna go is gonna give
it to them like it is in my opinion it
is evident that they still don't seem to
have a lot to show and I'm saying so you
know we're kind of getting this kind of
stuff and you know hopefully like I said
by as it improves all maybe as it gets
close to III they actually show more
anticipate because people had the
expectations higher they like all we're
gonna get you know I'm saying and I'm
like my family I mean I'm used to it's
not Xbox yeah I keep the expectations
really low but a king with this man no
it was our guard both we got games those
exclusives first of all the Final
Fantasy is not exclusive sorry Jonathan
Hart yeah I read your joint I know you
gonna put money up there so I'm gonna
read your number come at you
right now it's not exclusive baby its
own you got the inferior version and I
will be playing the superior but I will
definitely not be playing lemur lust
that would not be a thing I don't know
the concept of the game I don't care
about it I don't care about jumping off
a roof and floating up with my little
lemur wings I don't nothing about that
that game the foliage what was it
foliage plus it was ill holy its plus
tech demo foliage like engine and I want
you all to see how we go put this lemur
to the world so you could check out the
foliage oh that that animal game in
trailer like some like discover I know I
don't
according to what the game is supposed
to be like this you're in a world that's
like I guess on the cusp of like
destruction so there's a bunch of
natural disasters happening and you're
supposed to try to get away and I guess
in order to kind of procreate and move
evolution forward so if you don't
survived and whatever but I think that
you can jump from species to species
that colorful are in the game oh look
Sony's looking back at the Indies after
he left them in the bush when the chips
are low in decrease what we got going on
in the indie Creek no I've never had to
post this tool Twitter me know what it
is you see that's Xbox riding in you
feel that this was not impressive you
feel that oh okay
it was though it was the worst place
okay y'all keep saying it's in the
direct right but he said oh okay scrap
those three up throw that there and you
hit them with the Final Fantasy a go
walnuts over there but isn't that
multi-planet it's gonna be but doesn't
that what Microsoft is every year at e3
you know what this would they show with
that's a show hey Nicole and diamond you
showing a superior version when it's
almost exclusive yeah you know it's
basically exclusive because they can't
do 4k so you were a noted their 4k is
gonna be over here hey it's a different
game this is a different what are you
feeling about this say about the sony
state will let you transition I like it
yeah okay okay people here's the thing
people keep
getting what kind of presentation this
is this I would consider this more of a
presentation not a show right like I
would consider inside Xbox moreover show
than a brigade in a presentation you
know it's always quick to the point and
you show the numbers you move on I do
out of all of them I do like direct more
then it's indirect because I feel like
for the most part they generally have
better news yeah but I honestly think
Sony does the one better than I inside
expose you know Microsoft needs to take
note in just the damn video that's like
they could do their their show stuff but
they they gotta conserve something they
can't let it run too long they've been
getting better but at the end of the day
unless you have some crazy news nut it
should never be over 30 minutes no I
would you say yeah so we go get to the
main event
let's go Adi at the end of that they
showed Final Fantasy 7 this is the first
time I've seen anything on this game
since like what 2014 or 15 yeah pretty
much
for years and that and crazy like I feel
like this game isn't even close to being
done to what about all right so with
they showed the initial looks like we
still in what mid go right yeah the
whole the whole game was there was one
point cuz Sephiroth wasn't in Midgar you
never physically saw him and midgard
right and they did have a cutscene where
Sephiroth was there now I don't think
that is I don't think that that is in
the game that cutscene that if it's in
the game it's like a mental thing cloud
scene in his head okay because I think
the reason that was thrown in there is
because they wanted to show you
Sephiroth what he looked like
what he sounded like I think that was
important to them one thing that I'm
really curious about is you know I have
a couple questions for the panel one
question is do you think that this game
is gonna captivate the the original
audience that it did when it came out
because I don't think it is I think
people
like it to the table is he gonna have
that same feet feel what do you think
it's gonna be as relevant as a voice yes
no not at all now you mean relevant to
the same people who love the first one
or just two new people to both I think
this I think this is mainly I hope you
think this is to the same demographic
like I really don't like I don't not at
all I mean because I think again like
nostalgia you know that game was a very
time and place thing that game was the
first Final Fantasy game that was away
from Nintendo first CD based game like
where you know they had the orchestral
music and like it was a big event like
if you didn't like RPGs you still
probably got Final Fantasy 7 because of
how big it was how much of an event it
wasn't gaming at that time and this
isn't that so unless you're I guess for
people who have nostalgia for that game
just to see how different it is yes I
think they'll be excited for it but I
don't think it's gonna be this
world-changing thing and I think for for
people who've never played the original
I think you know you already have
something that's similar to it like if
you play if you play 15 and you sort of
have an idea of how they're approaching
this game so I don't you know I don't I
think it's gonna be good
I hope they're able to pull off this
episodic thing they're trying to do
they're gonna mess this game of yeah I
mean it is a there's a distinct
possibility of that that's for sure the
game they have nothing over beautiful
like I don't play the Final Fantasy
games Kingdom Arts is done messed up
seven Square Enix
I dare you I I will boycott their games
for the rest of my life
oh you boycott now after you tweet if
they mess up Final Fantasy 7
I will boycott the whole company oh my
god or is our boycott that publishing
games that they published you this man
right here with the backtrack yo hey
look look fire like I low for the no
unexpected trash it look fire like what
would King say hot fire I was open
orphanage like I was like yo ok cool now
granny I know what can go and say it's
multi-play yeah probably
but at the end of the day like it was so
shown on their platforms over on a
platform it looked good it got people
had because it went away
remember we heard it was a lot of
development issues going on with this
thing so we had to see but I'm with
solved like we got to see how they
handle the episodic pacing you know
sound what's the other goal here's the
other question pricing like they know
they sitting on cash cow with this so
for me I mean I know I'm gonna bend the
knee on that 60 because this is like
like so I've said like this was such an
event like Final Fantasy if you even
weren't into RPGs like you bought that
game that's really one of the first game
we've had a lot of people on our ILP
when we talk about Final Fantasy that
was the game someone you know that they
really got into RPGs for the first time
so we got to see that
how many parts is gonna be right we got
to see that it's gonna be three right
and then the other thing is this for me
actually be I'm a turn-based guy right I
like enemy go I go enemy go I go this is
not this is Final Fantasy 15
is that gonna upset the purists right
the purists like the classic joint and
I'm saying so to me adds it I thought I
would be upset but I actually watched it
I'm like you know what it's gonna make
it fresh you know say that's just me how
I'm looking at it and then my only thing
solved oh yeah I better have my material
y'all better have my son one way any
meaty when it come what it comes of
summons I think we're gonna see your
your Sheva your your effort yeah Knights
the realm step of the confinement I want
to wait a full seven minutes for Knights
around all the Knights they hit you I
want to see The Sitter man but I'm wrong
but there's a lot of random summons and
seven that I don't think it's gonna be
in this game we'll have a problem and we
better have that music the battle music
that I like when you're in it that's
classic please give me a nice little
remix or an arrangement or give me the
option to switch back and forth look
they got one but here's the day but when
is the let me ask this to the room
Willie I think this is coming out that's
here really I think the first episodes
coming out this year really
and there's no reason to pause it's
really there's no reason to pop this
state of whatever this is called at
state of play and then say come in in
June they said why would you why would
you double T that is true but they did
the same thing with Bethesda did the
same thing to fallout you do the initial
tease and you announce a release date in
in the holiday mmm interesting if this
game was not coming out this year this
would have been at this would have been
out there the one we just saw now would
have been at e3 no it wouldn't be a
reason to show it again super check the
trailers show material it's cloud
thought there we go you saw I was sleep
right you sleep until you put that baby
I think I think that the I think this
could come out and either at the end of
this year at the beginning of next and
what no no I am the reason I say that is
because there's absolutely no reason to
tease this game again like why would you
tease this game twice and within a month
of each other when you know the games
that could have come out for a whole
year this righteous said he told you he
said first quarter 2020 and that's what
he's thinking and I think it's going to
be $40 this is episodic I think it's
going to be 40 but that's this is what I
wanted to ask how do you think they
break this game up in terms of what
parts of the stories where do you think
they cut off the first one's gonna hit
or magar right right what you take the
second one at it the second one's gonna
end when you uh after you take the ship
to I don't know that there's a couple
like there's not a lot of dead zones in
the game that you could just end the
story it'll be fine like maybe that this
second win right when the weapons and
stuff come out right with the live
stream in the last part of the game will
be fighting the weapons fighting
Sephiroth himself he disrespect we said
they gonna break it up one episode for
Bush I don't think I think this is gonna
have four parts in the game but here my
issue another is I don't want to play
the first part and then at the way two
years of play the second part see that's
the thing man you have no idea how long
they take it for each of these and then
what they showed in the trailer was
basically a polished version of what
they showed in 2015 it was basically a
lot of the same sort of stuff same areas
just better looking um so I don't know
pretty good though yeah yeah but it's
the question is how much do you think
they're expanding on what you know on
what you had in summon because if it
they there aren't then there's no reason
to make it episodic I can pull a Sony
they can have half the game be cutscenes
like imagine all the talking I was in
seven now put that in dialogue let's get
King King so excited about first um yeah
I think one I'm gonna hit the
demographic got the old enemy um that's
the reason why the install jizz there um
a lot of you guys that are sitting there
to anticipate in this game is older
dudes don't want it um that no guys are
gonna see what it's about when it comes
out the reason why this game is so
important for the older guys
is it like psalmist said it benchmarked
time like it kind of stayed the same as
um old RPGs but then it gave you the
cinematic effect of the DES CD this is
when the cartridge versus CD thing was
going on and Sony had to show the reason
why CD was superior to cartridge and the
reason why it was necessary for Final
Fantasy to be on CD
now that game showed
all the reasons you needed to have a
Playstation right if you didn't have a
Playstation you when I was so many
people going out to buy the game because
they thought it was like a movie it was
an action whatever they didn't even know
was RPG it was people buying Final
Fantasy just off of the commercial
that's right and that was the time that
was the leap that we saw in graphics
when they was a little polygon guys but
then it switched off to the cinematics I
don't know what anybody said your
PlayStation was at his prime right then
and there you know you not satisfying it
was to call up a summons the first
summons that you got and you had it you
I know everybody that had a controller
stood up clapped it was like this is
what all my money without raising a
couple of things in the game I really
wanted a curious how they handle like
the weapons they're so huge I don't know
how you're gonna fight them in the 15k
gameplay combat system changing is
definitely gonna be interesting not a
hand right I'd like to see certain
cutscenes in the game Bri brought back
like the weapon blowing up the big gun
on on in bloom and I kind of want to see
how they handle certain aspects of the
weapons in general like emerald weapon
underwater like how you supposed to
fight them underwater like that like in
this new combat like I just don't that's
the biggest issue I have with this it's
like translate a new combat system with
you know the traditional story because
then things have to change
no you're making a good point you're
making a good [ __ ] right um hopefully
that they're able to tell you that you
can either play in traditional mode or
the pneumo all right to alleviate all
that stuff because at this game I do
like it to be turn-based instead of
action-oriented base because a lot of
the action-oriented base games and it
kind of pushes me away from the feel of
the RPG those long separate entities
within a so yeah I don't I don't really
want that stigma or that they're feeling
associated with this game mm-hmm looking
forward to it I really believe that they
pulling at the heartstrings of the core
audience and I believe they're waiting
for that core audience to push it
through not as episodic stuff
it would sound like is great for
gamepads type of thing but because you
know the financial like you're sitting
here talking about 60 versus 40 verses
15 you're looking for the sweet spot and
where you're gonna be able to give up
the money if that's it the older guys is
gonna pay whatever it is right we can
write the did the new crowd that is
unsure about it that's what you gotta
try to get so I do believe I'm gonna go
with adequate the $40 really okay
because I think even with the remake
even with the graphical upgrades the
thing is people are they're gonna
promote this game is an older game
coming into the new generation I mean it
has remaking it same people to remake it
long that was different though that was
that came through I don't know but I'll
be I got a good point I see what King at
you and King Kong I'm sorry cocky cocky
but I honestly truly believe that
finding a finance your sweet spot for it
is it's what is about but I do it
doesn't lend to a games of service yes a
game so hopefully PlayStation now or
whatever their new thing will be called
going forward and Xbox um game pass
ultimate would adopt this game into the
game pass and the PlayStation now
subscription based type of thing if you
want to buy go ahead and buy it but if
it's available in-game pass and stuff
like that that would be big if it came
out perfect I think the game comes out
in July or August
I think it comes out in this summer to
give us through these months because
there's no reason for them the short
here and then they're gonna tell you I'm
game I'm gonna give you information so I
believe it's coming out this year but I
believe it's coming out a whole lot
sooner than you guys think I think I'm
just one point that you may want to
expound on one point which is good King
that she was talking about the
turn-based a parody of that right and
I'm with you on that aspect I think the
reason why they're doing it and adding
you could let me know if you agree is
they know that the new generation young
generation right I haven't played that
turn-based that ol ladylike is that
Final Fantasy 15 right so I think that's
why they go on arrow but I do agree with
you King like they need the option right
they hopefully I don't know if it's
positive
technically it's possible but it would
be cool if they had that after it is a
good thing is it would be basically two
different systems though they load the
game twice and give you the option so
you look like it's gonna be the show
it's gonna be the 15 like there's not
can you haven't picked off the hawk or
they'll be they didn't care about it in
12 they didn't care about in 15 but this
is like but this is like but love this
is like a revered final fantasy like
people like it the way it was some
people I mean we'll see I mean best
feeling is like if you want to play that
go play Dragon Quest
I'll go Cueto well we got something for
you it turns into you don't sell as much
as your competition and I think that's
an issue yes are we gonna continue like
safe points obviously we could do like
cross save and you know a lot of things
is cloud but cross-generational title in
my opinion and I'm saying like it'll
definitely who knows we'll see it we got
to see when that launches but I do think
the first episode is gonna be on the ps4
and Xbox one and the second is gonna be
on next-gen you know what we should do
well we made super chair we should
actually do a little segment around a
super chair that is a great honestly
believe that is gonna launch a
PlayStation 4 I don't think it's not fit
well it's gonna be cross generational
because they said it backwards
compatible right once you slide to find
our through the home but I do I do a
surprise cuz they do say is backward
compatible so once you slide your debit
card
yeah you didn't notice on your
Playstation 4 right now those little
slats in between is a debit card they
took the beach out because they do
explode it's like you had a swipe the
car to turn it on turn that real quick I
don't know the how much traction this
whole this thing is got in Bora what are
you guys thinking about the of the extra
mister mister deification of Barry
oh listen our reserve judgment until I
hear more dialogue until I fill out your
I'm saying play the game these games
have notoriously bad dialogue in there
and then sometimes things get messed up
in translations you know Jeff thing I'm
not trying to say ain't clowning them
you know say I don't know I don't know
it's back in the days when they did that
Barret that it was a homage to mr. T and
when remember mr. t ba Baracus was there
so I know in this day and age you may
look like clown him but it's still a
homage to that delayed like take the
great mr. t like he is his his persona
was larger than life back then so a lot
of strong black characters and leads
were probably leaning on him so I
thought it was nice and I'm glad that
they keep him with it just go with it
listen I got to see more before I can
make any type of determinations on
either social and racial issues I got
esteem or I just saw like literally a
second or two of him but it look at me a
static dis cuz I did hear something
about the voice people are complaining
about right something someone with the
voice with Barrett is it something like
inaccurate assembly I guess they're
referring to the average children
Barrett yeah but if there were burn to
Final Fantasy sevens bear he didn't have
a voice
you know so for me is like it is what it
is but people eyes like I I mean I
sensed it I heard the
Prince but I'm like not one of these
people that like flip out when someone
as long as the voice is semi close to
the original rule I'm not really have a
huge issue like I was the kind of dude
when they switched um war machine in the
very first Ironman I didn't even know
this you just finish up at that you're
your hype are you nervous
are you ready that we're so you really
because it's your baby she the Master
P's on literally put his knees on this
if they mess it up he just said he will
never so and that means if they come out
with a remake of the remake and is
better than last he can't buy it if our
Fantasy 7 is remade to remake it to a
pill to the remade then the original
cartridge is too many caveats to meet a
loophole king that we on the Sony
subject um there are some PlayStation 5
rumors going on do you want to get into
that Sarah oh I want to get it to price
I want to get into release dates
oh yes so good a Sony fans you notice
our preface that with us a Sony fans
they saying that the system's gonna be
$4.99 $500 don't don't act like $100
it's $500 plus they one controller no
game baby
so you know you gotta buy a game cuz you
know you can't go back
I know debit card down the side to play
the old game so we're gonna buy that new
guseva [ __ ] [ __ ] that right
so we coming out in 21 they're gonna ask
you to slide that card in the upgraded
version to Gus if you see you you know
how we go you want to play in 4k you got
to play today
so I'm saying now that is $500 really in
on this price tag so we're looking at I
was gonna come in Wailord an Xbox reader
talk about 350 no it's 550 now
what's up let's let's give the catch X
there was research institute analyst
sadecki Yasuda so he basically he gave
his analysis of the Sony business and
said that um like King is saying like
the UM he expects it to launch in
November 2020 and like King is saying
$4.99 in the West he thinks it will sell
six billion units in the fiscal year and
then he took some shots off say it also
mentions that cloud gaming and stadia
won't be a threat for PlayStation so he
he coming I feel luminous my man like
that I really appreciate that slander on
Stadium but uh that's where yet with it
so uh according to King like what what
are you thinking what are y'all thinking
as far as like solve like this whole do
you think this is far-fetched you think
it's right on the money
wait like I want to know how much these
dudes get paid to give the these Captain
Obvious frickin prediction about pay me
and I told you this a year ago this is
what its gonna be like it's obvious it's
coming out next year so that's nothing
and in the timing yeah they've always
launched in November could they throw a
curve ball there and launch it earlier
yeah and that's that's something that is
definitely a possibility
so either or like it's it's November or
it's probably March or April one of
those two yeah here we go let's get her
attic what do you think about this man
500 November where is this is this
doable this what it is
attic think it's gonna be 400
get on it which he did ago shout out
agree I think they're gonna take the hit
and make up for it in software because I
think I'm like last gen with this chin
they're going to have consistent games
coming out because that's when all their
games just start popping off and they'll
know they'll make the money back are but
what about what about that was where so
what I'm gonna say like that coming in
with such a high right the 91 million so
supposedly with the saying you know do
you think is solve says is this the time
for them to mess up and show arrogance a
little bit you know say it kind of like
oh they're already doing that they're
gonna be sculpting dumb I can tell you
that yeah for whatever the dumb they've
they've done is washed away that's the
price you thought it was well based on
the tech that we hearing right it's
sound and we had mods on the show and a
lot doing a show in reference to it the
rumors like it sounds pretty beefy it
sounds like it's something like it will
be it sounds like it would be hard for
them to they can cut in that regard but
I'm hard drive a low life oh honey air I
don't I don't get that bit that would be
a big hit a huge hit it's just I don't I
don't see it happening I don't see right
now what people saying 600 in the chat
you you you want crack nut and like that
reason with the get it is gonna be 600
once if they launched that game is six
but it comes out with blood-borne to
horizon zero dawn two and another until
don't matter also Sony is not dropping
at it is not like they add
and maximum five munch at maximum money
I mean the four other thing is
interesting we got to see again if they
can realistically take the cut but on
what you saw this is like obvious stuff
to me like this is November that's the
sweet spot you know but the question
comes down to are they gonna do that and
I don't know if they necessarily have to
cut to 400 being that they are the
market leading is so dominant is so
synonymous with the next generation with
people coming over you know I think that
was one of the main reasons that xbox
got butchered out the gate was the prime
Xbox has that the initial unit coming
out is 4 and PlayStation has that 500
they better have a good launch up or I
think they're going to get her yeah
absolutely I mean I think the most
interesting thing in this article was
the fact that was the the shot at stadia
and I know the streaming stuff because
he made it he made it seem like they're
not even that that's not a lane they're
really considering they may be saying
whatever they're saying but it's not a
lane that they're heavily considering
the way Microsoft the way Google is and
I think that would be a mistake a but be
I mean it does sort of point to
something I saw an article about this a
while back I forgot where I saw it but
it was like basically that Nintendo and
Google and Microsoft had seated the the
traditional console market to place the
PlayStation is is is down that old path
that we know and they you know that's
recognizable and then Microsoft and
Nintendo all these people are treading
new ground yeah so it's and it's sort of
does make sense because I think for Sony
to continue to maintain that dominance
they need to focus on what they've been
strong at and what they've been strong
at is the traditional console right not
deviating from that I think they come
out at 500 and they don't have a big
blockbuster as an exclusive I think
that's gonna that's gonna hurt them
don't know like they're sitting on so
many good titles like five years to make
one game and then the thing is if they
do that right and they don't have the
blockbuster right and then Lockhart is
comparable in price and power and no
it's less if Lockhart is cheaper and
comparable in power
yeah they might have imagined okay I'll
leave the launch and so he's gonna have
something at launch obvious but like I
think it's gonna be good board to why it
would be stupid not to but the thing
about blood-borne
- is that blood-borne - as great as
blood-borne is it's still sort of a
niche title like it doesn't appeal to
everyone people then you think these
days oh yeah Oh Ian's every time they
come out now so we get you say in that
jar is nice but that's right but that's
why they that's why they launch with
neck right like things like that like
now we'll say this launch of a console
you really just look at the at the
beginning at the very launch of a
console you're just really on there to
get the hard core invested right the
hard core they bought your last system
normal consoles we would have that to
really look at but I think this gen is
gonna be different than your average
launch of a console right you you have
aspects like fully backwards compatible
you know right we some because some you
have all digital where people are locked
to a certain platform because of the
previous gen then delete all of their
games there mmm-hmm I mean you you got
uh I don't think there's ever been a
time where well we don't really know
what Microsoft's doom where Sony Studios
have been so stacked right where they
had good games coming out consider it
sitting on a ton of sequels this yeah
they could easily make a lot of these
things cross they're only picking up
more studios um this moment that they're
picking up more suiting listen they
giving up for the fight alright I'm the
fight is like I told y'all before is
against the wax stadia Amazon and Google
and these guys um and you have to
understand this this stuff is and and if
Netflix decide to do something as far as
gaming wise you know they have to
prepare for the onslaught that's coming
up
go ahead they have to get all these
Studios in pocket now and show them that
listen we we start out time out stick
with the $2 1:19 ride to LA super check
Sony is well under price to fight listen
we know they couldn't anaconda is more
powerful so it will be more money I
think the reason you're doing that is
because I think Andy Kahn has been in
$5.99 but I think that's a good you are
right sir and I do believe that they
will undercut anaconda you that is a
question then become which is good but
the question then becomes where does
Lockhart fall in this right because if
I've right and what we're gonna assume
we're gonna assume anacondas five I know
I think any cons b6o
I think anaconda six real eyes with his
gin they came out with the underpowered
system got obliterated from resolution
but then they launched the X and nothing
happened that they never got attacked
over that again I did on a price point
which had proven everyone was worried
about the price pool because that's your
hardcore people they're gonna buy that
regardless if you are call were very
concerned that the X is going to Latin
launch at 500 I remember me a couple
other people were like when it launched
that we like yell 400 be the right thing
to kill the game and he launched at five
everybody
all they messed up I remember those
conversations I remember us doing i LPS
and the fire and allah price point was
announced with you know they squeezing
their pennies and they're crying and let
me tell you something start saving now
you know you don't know a year ahead of
time that you can't take $10 away from
your paycheck or 20 hours away from your
paycheck so then when the system do come
out you're not selling the car outside
in the parking lot
you listen save your punt your pennies
save your nickels that you don't have to
sell the farm when it shows up and you
know yeah
I've seen it I see everybody wait to the
last minute this entire conversation
[Music]
much credit they made mistakes they
continue to make them they have been
overlooked because Microsoft has made
more mistakes and that won't ever happen
again
mm interesting $10 oh you know what that
is a great topic a prank I don't
honestly believe what you're saying is
that Microsoft has made more mistakes
than sony Sony see the overlooked thing
that makes me the make the thing that
makes me think that $600 the possibility
is because they've been rock solid on
this point that they will not be
undercut in power again now if you're
looking at two systems whose comparable
in space then how then how do you make
that assurance unless you know that
yours is gonna be more expensive and I
do think that you know the Anaconda the
reason that it's gonna be so much
because this particular contour don't
think they're gonna taken a loss on at
all go back to the fact that he said
that you know it's um the the mistakes
that these guys have made do you think
their mistakes is overlooked because
listen Sony has capitalized on
Microsoft's own mistakes and that's what
put them in this position in a yeah but
he's how you trade use games I thought
it was great it was you know stuff like
that would never fly this now like
people would be like that's too much
listen I'm at end of the day we willing
to put that knee up you're on that one
suicide what 600 in my opinion condom
okay
Tommo March with 600 and the hint have
another one to go at a lower price their
thing is that we're gonna get we're
going to drop a console that's pretty
much like the ex to the to the s right
now of
chin that way we could beat them at
price because you could buy the ass of
next gen and then if you want to go
extra extra you can pay the extra 200
and beat and go beat them at power say
that's the smart choice PlayStation 3
that was the only option no the only
option I understand your point you're
saying if y'all want the big boy system
you get anaconda for six and you want
the little boy system you do whatever
you're saying that's awkward to matter
600 is a great you come $200 cheaper
than the place to which the PS 5 yeah
again I know where you're going with it
because you're saying because there's a
lot like they they're they're more
they'll be more there they wouldn't have
the fear to raise anaconda amount with
open statements like we're gonna have
the stronger system but your systems to
say cost so chances are it's gonna be
around the same you don't know that
these guys have great an optimization
man these guys are great in the hardware
right so if these guys are 5 why can't
these guys be father they take the hit
not on the superiority in price I mean
they you know when you go inside a store
something is the same thing you get a
snide I like something has been fact
proven then you see a higher price tag
and they equate that with higher quality
and we saw how that fact proven started
at the beginning this generation with
the Xbox so 500 and they 400 and 600 PS
5 500
400 if the lock is less powerful than
the playstation 5 is 2013 all over again
only Xbox can be too expensive and cheap
at the same time and what's a man at the
end of the day they just went who it is
are we really gonna ignore history or
people but you're comparing it's not
apples to apples because again you don't
the to skew thing matters
it really does yeah you right again we
still don't know what said skew is we
don't know the power all the way in
comparison the Lockhart in comparison to
and what if Lockhart even though we I'm
not surprised now but let's finally do
this definitely hit the mark I'm looking
at a 600 504 don't agree with that and
like he said only Microsoft can be more
powerful and less powerful at the same
time but you know what that's called
diversity and doing that is because they
don't want that something to happen it's
beginning this chin they don't want to
be attacked as a resolution and they
don't want to be attacked for price so
if you put those scenarios out there
like never since the X come out has
anyone really said anything about the
price of performance-wise on consoles
not really because it's they don't have
the cash a Sony has to put out no 600
ala system they know they've got so much
to prove with software right now people
go say he will be a pay 600 to ever show
me games
that's a JB gamer with like the second
or third Saturday game was a fickle in
the 360 gen and was all about online
multiplayer games this gen single-player
games the question is can Microsoft make
next-gen play to their strengths they
can and they will
but district 8 haven't been first
delivering that's really that's the
reason they give you the $40 console
okay let's listen listen JD is
definitely on a mark right here right
I'm good with me going forward and
they're showing these studios in these
games I believe they're gonna be
starting to play to their strengths and
contradicting their state and CP telling
you I think that III is gonna show a lot
it is gonna justify the cost of these
systems going forward but you know why
the thing is that what is shown
Microsoft to me and is shown that they
care less and less about the box
so the fact that they offer you a $600
box is not gonna hurt them or at least
in perception gonna hurt them because
they're just worried about where they're
delivering the games to us and how they
I don't what the what the media
attacking is gonna be oh of course but
again bass was $600 necessarily if if
the Anaconda does what they say it's
gonna do it's gonna be drastically an
improvement but you still got the LA car
if you want to go play that for the 399
if you want to you can get the flat
$5.99 for the increased performance I
don't think the media's gonna attack
them because at the beginning of the gym
we didn't have the Lockhart you just had
it by the end of Condit right so people
were comparing the prices and not to
mention since the Kinect it ruined that
price range so pretty much paid more for
less
yep good because it was underpowered and
you had a piece of hardware that was in
the box that you didn't want then the
messaging was wrong then innocent I
honestly believe that they're gonna come
off and they gonna start this generation
a whole lot better different people in
charge with different agendas listen
this is a company that has so much to
prove in the next generation and I'm
saying it just it just so much so that
you got understand like people who are
in that Sony ecosystem they're not
leaving until they see something that
says wow that's gonna knock my socks off
$600 is not the goal but
$300 might be the goal for what game
first
obviously the game grow is gonna be the
right you've gotten away feed it
nothing happens without telling you
what's the ingredients right listen I
got a PC that I don't play that cause
way more than all of them right because
there's no games that's compelling me to
do it but I saw the on the via no stop
there new oculus another not oculus the
valve one they add new vive um I want
that and that's optimize my PC for me
right that's another thousand dollars
that's neither here nor there but I you
need to show the software I believe
Microsoft on this e3 stage they're gonna
show the software that's going to compel
you to make that choice now are you
gonna ditch up your arm your existing
library hold on here we go one more game
game let's get that game a baby cuz I
love you on it
alright I'm gonna owe a power/lock price
lock new studios for new IPS lock old IP
favorites coming back lock they will
have it all again it sounds nice it's a
PlayStation 3 they just like you're
talking they had two schools they had
600 Allah and they had the little one
with the 20 gig hard drive in this
problem cheaper outcome and you can get
the best for the end of conduct that's a
completely different scenario it's
different scenario it's not a different
because it Paisley was fundamentally the
same machine it's just storage so and
they say receive right pretty but we we
saw those documents from cobra land you
know they never told you they never told
you CPU speed they never told me it's
the same bike run at a different you
know listen this is don't don't front
then Lockhart is for the budget gamer
alright let's let's just keep it a
fisherman it's for the budget gamer then
now we're gonna look over at the
Anaconda that's for the extreme gamer
right so that's for that guy with the 4k
television aka television that God is
actually doing those things right now
you're looking over at the the lower end
the the lower end for the guy who didn't
make the jump to for Kate who's who just
wants to get in that's get extra
PlayStation do who still has his
PlayStation and says let me see what
this this egg rock stuff is about so he
can take that he can jump into the Xbox
pool without taking a bath right and so
this this situation it lends to good
market this is the first time shoutout
to Aaron Greenberg on the team the first
time I could say ice truly see your
vision going forward and I think this is
the smart way going for it now I will
say this we don't that to me the wild
card is the Lockhart right right if a
lot car is comparable to the PlayStation
5 can look it in the eye then I'm with
y'all because what you pay 400 we're
assuming I'm sick like let's just say
when digital frowns you do them break
down 64 K forget that bike again it it's
comparable right and Lockhart can hold
its own and then you give the casual
gamer that nice entry point and you can
say hey you're on par with what they're
doing then I can see that eases the bro
and then the hard core of the
enthusiasts like us who get the elite
controllers and all that other stuff
they'll go get player six on a lie
machine they can get away with in but if
it's not let's just say you're mopping
like the PlayStation 5 is substantially
better than the Lockhart nah fam that's
a L all right all right let me let me
let me just spend on your point real
quick to reload on you right I think
that it's going to be the ultimate 1080p
system right I agree I think it's going
to be I think it's going to do all the
effects of all the 4k stuff without
being 4k it's gonna be that 1080p be
hardcore let's get it all in it
so whatever but you telling me that you
think the Lockhart is going to be less
potent than the X I'm not saying oh yeah
I'm not even citing an expert it's less
powerful
the next I think the accident we already
said GPU I mean yeah right what it is
but again to me if the battle is
Lockhart and PlayStation 5 because it's
no that's to me because if they come up
with that low price point and it's just
as powerful as a 5 it's not gonna do for
ok I'm not close to I forget to forget
about DGP you asked I'm just talking
about culture as far as the CPU frame
rates all those stuff Jenny expect yeah
but I think is gonna do that it's gonna
do all that it's gonna be the 1080 keep
up with the big boy stuff I agree coggan
that that if it's not comparable and the
PS 5 is considerably more powerful then
at that point you cannot price the
Anaconda s6 you can't you just can't
okay cuz people come to let you why am I
gonna switch to y'all
PlayStation 5 smacking animal fur do ya
want me to pay $600 for that now imma
stay over here well my place is your
father my library for 500 I'm telling
you that's what game is it I mean for
the to school thing to really work that
Lockhart has to be comparable in price
and powers at FPS 5 I think I think it's
gonna be around the same power bounty
cuz I think that the PS 5 is gonna
outperform it digital foundry - no but I
do think it is gonna perform better
we're speculating about this I'll tell
you right now I Microsoft knows exactly
what Sony's doing and Sony knows exactly
what they're doing
I think thing here is is they want the
perception and they want the narrative
being different than it was last gen
they want that high call us of
regardless what price it is so so they
don't constantly being compared on
resolution all the time they're like
look okay if resolution is that
important to you don't go by the
Anaconda right I don't know okay and a
fourth anaconda you can buy the cheaper
console on the market so it'll be
interesting see I play that as a good
disc
I'm dying to know about that Lockhart
now like God but anyway we will get into
a good talking points from the Lord's oh
what a jump move on my tablet right now
we got a launch of a new game Ghost
Recon break point to gameplay trailers
from Ubisoft ain't out it looks like it
is the direct wildlands replacement
replace of it but no replacement rate of
replacement this is gonna be the next
wave you know I'm saying it go on they
say and pretty much is a fictional story
it's not gonna have any type of um you
know this is pretty much like no
political message or anything like that
and all that lot of people has some
issues with that but I want to start to
suffer the laws anybody has seen the
trailers and if who have seen it what
are your initial thoughts my initial
thoughts as I love it on that thing
that's all that is all play this game I
don't really like Ghost Recon like that
but that haptic though the full
succession quote-unquote replacement but
oh yeah I honestly think it looked
fantastic I think it's gonna get all of
us back to game and how we used to you
know play that on the ghost recon joint
you know team up and call our shots
stuff like that
I love the fact that they got the
Punisher as the bad guy and I think I
did you know what I think this is gonna
make that name ring bells you gotta
understand why people get warm and fuzzy
when the hair goes recon I saw like he
was running he was taping up his leg and
into his people he's coming over the
hill he's like you they following me
oh hi Corey today I say raid I don't
know let me ask you this on first
did you get a chance it yeah I saw both
plain meaning to me the most exciting
thing for me is all of the the survival
stuff that King mentioned and also the
new stealth stuff that they mentioned
Ghost Recon wildlands was wasn't as much
focused on on stealth as past Ghost
Recon games and that was I mean that
that's that was Ghost Recon like that to
me just you know it it took the rainbow
sticks formula and took it outside right
yeah
and wild loans was great but it to me
just felt more like it was very
action-oriented less about the stealth
less about in reach and stuff like that
where is this is about survival this is
about stealth this is about infiltration
I saw a lot of things that I liked and I
hope I hope to god they're implementing
in the new Splinter Cell like the prone
takedowns you think using the mud like
to hide yourself the things I like all
that stuff honestly I secretly just want
all that stuff in the next winner so
hopefully that this is like the proving
ground for it but man like that stuff
look great to me I love that I mean
that's the same thing I mean initially
would call me off full perón you don't
say that stealth when you said putting
the modelview going completely on some
chaotic amazing it's a it's a ubisoft
game Assassin's Creed with guns its
third party for a cry it's the same gag
for division and watchdog stop playing
ma justice saying god I predict an
anthem to win um overall Division two
just won't put them out there doing it
[Music]
we said put that join super jet so King
to read it and they get infinitely get
into yeah with the smart move I don't
you shade the fire super jet but if
you're way over zero
I gotta agree with the man anthems MVP
[Music]
it dethrones everything do I don't want
to last them so I just want anthem -
right now - I think at the 1:1 anthem -
Patrick that break point they go with
their yo you know we have me to solve a
king like that like I said that real
injury the limp in you know saying when
I was great stand the pick the character
up you know I'm saying if you're getting
more with a safety that kind of thing
you're talking about you got to eat for
survivability yeah talking about Crafton
Nikita yeah yeah that was they give yeah
absolutely
they I was shocked he said rains that
surprised me I was like raids and turn
me off I solve it stick a place all day
like that that's me
I'm thinking with this whole thing now
they see crazy uh-oh shout out to JD
gamer he's back in the piltan Johnny the
truth teller will Sony even survived
next generation now that Microsoft is
actually taking gaming serious
rest in peace Sony why don't let that
King let me tell you something I think
III will reveal all to everyone I
honestly believe Sony ain't gonna be
able to hold a mouth shut on the data
Microsoft unveils all these games I
think Sony actually gonna say something
that daytime XO me to be Petty and been
on that day because they are not held in
any constraints they're roaming around
the halls we don't know winning on take
these shots and makes them unpredictable
I like unpredictable soda right just go
how are you three yeah I think Sony
gonna do do something no matter what
anybody says Ubisoft has found the
perfect way to keep their games alive
and going with constant support and
update their like I don't care
they are Ubisoft the best developer and
publisher yes got it they learn from
their mistakes and
they have a formula in place that just
works and they any work at it it's not
like they throw it out there and they
leave it out there to die like how is it
you turn for honor around iku anybody
else would have dropped that game cold I
don't succeed each addict stuck around
with it and it got fantastic they sat
down with the division they sat down
with their games they stayed they pushed
through if they make a game they commit
to a game they commit to the to the
consumer and Ubisoft has been the most
consumer friendly developer this
generation I think hands down if you buy
Ubisoft game you understand that you got
the full backing of Ubisoft so I think
that's a smart move on their part going
forward that you can trust them you can
believe in they company I think that I
did yeah I got me listen man you bees
been on it man so last thing I was gonna
say obviously you know John whatever I
pronounce the sauce burn go change came
from the walking dead
yeah so you look like he's an X ghost
you don't know saying that's fine right
so he had the the expansion that just
came out for wild lands that introduces
him and shows how it progresses into
this next one I know I got it I know
this Sam you know what you call it oh
yeah we you haven't thrown it on since
it was exit hand just went back to
destiny was super lit I thought that
predator joint was tried Emma I didn't
know that it had that continuous I
didn't know he was introduced in the end
of that that's no I didn't know that so
let me ask this to afford more down I
shot a question bring us the king now
with everything we saw a break boy how
lit look is Ubisoft making a mistake
with killing its own game in Division
two I had this conversation on the last
word with each salute the ebon seized
and I'm just a little concerned cuz they
drop in October right then I guess King
like I'm a plane in the same Lane right
so you think like what the vision to to
raise the leg come out yet we still
waiting on that you know I know they got
episodic content and stuff that they're
gonna add but like is this a mistake to
drop you know breakpoint and out around
Division two when they kind of plan in
these same pockets all right I see this
is an extension of their world also a
lot of times when people purchase these
type of games like these military
strategic games they also buy them in
bunches usually you know one guy will
have seeds that will definitely have the
vision to or Division one I will lean
towards those type of games I think and
you just told me wild lands just
extended on this story so I would have
to go and play Wow
to take to get um brushed up on the
story but I think they wanted wild lands
to do more maybe so I think this takes
wild lands Lane the wild lands I don't
necessarily believe that it jumps inside
the ludus shooter Lane ride the engine
to because division 2 has constant
reoccurring yeah let me ask you this the
only reason why by now you're making a
good point cuz one is a looter shooter
right one is you know you get different
stuff and this is more of a cooperative
and it seemed very story and the only
thing I'm thinking it's just like what
about the fact that like they doing so
much more like outside you go full-blown
you don't say like they doing certain
actions that divisions just not do any
but I think in the cover system because
I think they went away from cover system
believe always didn't have snap to Gears
of War style cover yeah and now this is
kind of taking division sensibilities
and putting that in their thing I was
just worried in that what you think
about that solving can I think that
makes them different right I think when
you go back to Ghost Recon and what
Ghost Recon is and this feels like it's
going back to Ogle's we got a lot of
ways I think that the tactical elements
in a lot of ways I think it might feel
more like a rainbow succeeds in terms of
how tactical it is as opposed to a
division to division to like yes the
cover system and and sort of working
together with your teammates but
it is very much like you your enemies
are very aggressive is constant aggro
it's more about you moving from cover to
cover not staying not staying in one
place as opposed to Ghost Recon game is
about figuring out your best position
how to infiltrate um you know kind of
working with your teammates in that
regard it's it's a slower pace right and
I think division is I so I think the
fundamentally how the games play is
gonna be different and I think you have
different audiences because of that but
now feels you say I guess again they
threw me off when I heard scene raids
and I'm like whoa like this is just
straight for division but yeah it's
right um think about this they're
different world in like as far as
different stuff that you do I honestly
believe that the division 2 has a
different idea when they want to attack
stuff like the Rolly balls and stuff
like that I don't believe that stuff
would be implemented inside of this new
are Rainbow six I'm young
those game so I believe with their set
package it's going to be a different
feel not notice when they say raids they
might mean they don't want to say layers
right they don't want to say in control
O's they want to say something resonates
with people that make you pick you eyes
you're like wow buzzwords so I believe
it raid in a sense that yeah you're
gonna need your four buddies to handle
this part it's all gonna go in and
you're gonna do this and you're gonna
coordinate is going to be a water
activity yes right instead of saying
something like a stronghold that will
leave a bad taste in your mouth you
understand
Lord addict finish this up man what do
you think do you think on their in their
own lane with the division I really
don't care well let's get in there I
don't know
did you see the trailer sir no he didn't
watch because he didn't prepare for show
great awesome
first of all I don't know a lot of
you've seen this actually Atticus's we
can started off seeing he's so prepared
today um rage too has been in the news
attic did you you did see that y'all you
know the ass because I sent it to you do
you pay attention what's been going on
rage too and journalists yeah what's a
dude's name Paulo taxi he took you can't
even really take a shot at at the rage
developers he made pretty much an
article that's like we haven't seen no
marketing for h2 should you even buy it
because you don't even know it's coming
out next week it's kind of like give or
take what the article said uh first off
I don't know what he's talking about
scene or h2 ads everywhere every time I
watch a YouTube video chances are that
pops up I don't watch cable TV anymore
so I don't know if it's on there but uh
he pretty much made that article he
clickbait at the title a little bit and
uh rage Twitter account commented on
that and say who are you
so raised to Twitter account what did
all this smoke with him
people people were upset because you
know I guess that was a little uh
unprofessional
they didn't really attack him on a
personal level they just asked who he
was I felt like that that could be more
of a joke than anything else right so
you know the whole community split in
half half of them says oh he shouldn't
have done that it's unprofessional
the other half walk like me it's like
these devs get attacked all the time
can't get mad once one of them clawed
back mmm so you felt the clap back was
justified it was amazing there was some
talk that uh the Randy Pitchford had
hijacked the rage to Twitter a guy was
using that to get things off his trip
did you see the banter going back I did
I mean it the way first of all whoever
answered him like bad grammar fix your
grammar don't don't you don't diss
anybody if your grammar is wrong like
doesn't do
that so that it really felt like
somebody's kid got onto their Twitter
account was like yeah why you dis admit
rates to or whatever and answer like and
then after that I don't think they
really said anything else and then
Paulette aussi came back and was like
well I'm I'm just a concerned like
journalist who's interested in your game
and and I haven't seen any sort of
marketing push for it so he was being
very genuine about what he said and I
don't think I don't think he ever said
anything about why would you buy this
game you know you haven't seen anything
about it but he did indicate that he
hadn't seen anything about it angry with
addict I see it you know if you watched
a youtube video you probably don't see a
rage - advertisement I don't know how
you know TV there is no way that he did
that the intentions of trying to say
start something but he was definitely
trying to get people to click on that
article from yeah and I but I will admit
to like I haven't seen it I haven't seen
it to the point where it's like well
yeah the games coming out next week so I
did sort of forget it what yeah I did
sort of forget the game was coming out
soon so I get that in that regard and
yes it was click baby in the sense that
you'll get people talking about it I'm
sure if you refresh this this this
podcast sovereign you're gonna see a
rainbow commercial that is that the end
of the it says comes out next week well
obviously the day what else in a lot of
ways it felt like all of this is just
giving rage the advertisement that he
was talking in a way I'm sorry fine
finished off without getting I don't
know I don't think it's people going
back and forth I think if he had
answered it he answered this sort of
seriously after like they were like lol
who are you if he had answered it
jokingly from the jump I think none of
this would have happened but since he
answered it seriously then some people
took it seriously and then responded in
kind so now what it was so let me ask
you like what do you feel about a lot of
a lot of you know YouTube provocateurs
they a lot of journalists that came to
that said that that was unprofessional
that was on something that uh these guys
shouldn't have done but that's
that video quicker than they put out
that article oh ma yeah yeah I think I
mean to do it and then not even continue
to respond on it and say something to
the effect of like look we teach we just
felt like we were attacked a little bit
there whatever the case may be they
threw that out there I don't think there
was any other response from thinking
about it is true that he specifically
said look I know I probably shot myself
in the foot cuz I was in the process of
actively trying to secure a copy for
review
I was super I'm super interested in this
game I'm still AM so it was just me
saying listen I I wish there were more
out there about it because it feels like
this not enough to push this game and I
that I can understand because why do you
say that we say that in the beginning
money go Adam and then when you get shot
back in the back of the head well he
didn't go Adam like read the title it
was clickbait be in a sense like oh baby
title was enough right but it wasn't an
attack on them at all like no use hell
they see here's the thing like here is
he is a writer wellick stablished writer
for that matter he knows that a cliff
baby taro 80% of the people ain't even
clicking on that but the click baby
title wasn't does it didn't feel like it
was attacking them either it was just a
statement I understand your points off
but I do agree with Atticus sense that
in the sense that like it was kind of
throwing shade like maybe they haven't
done enough marketing so at people
should know about it right like it could
be interpreted that way I mean who knows
what the intention was right but it
could be interpreted way and maybe the
clap back is what king is saying is like
your family are you talking about who
will you but King little changes came
with chocolate King where did you act
with this whole
rage - versus Tassie and journaling
purses you know gaming me alright knows
one of the games that I was actually
looking forward to a lot because I like
rage one no it was a great game I
thought the world was fantastic I
thought the engine was great um in a 360
generation I thought it was fantastic so
the fact that they have rage - my mom we
saw there was coming lash it was like
yeah to his point I don't see and much
advertisement for the game as I would
like because I'm already gonna buy but I
know what he's saying he doesn't want
the game to fall flat he wants to gain -
you know - to continue to live on or
whatever so he wants to see
advertisement in that vein that they
showing it there behind the game mm-hmm
Elizabeth is a game there behind the
game was gonna get that push it's gonna
be pushed in different areas we don't
know if they're gonna do marketing of
that day and push it forward they
probably want to see initial sales you
got pre-orders ready right but they're
dealing with it with what the pre-orders
is done already those numbers is already
there now they wanna see exactly what is
an issue date of purchase numbers right
gonna see how you're gonna use marketing
going forward from that point but my
question I guess the question is was
because a lot of gaming journalists were
upset with the raves Twitter account on
the clap back yeah but these things is
real sensitive right now I can't um I
can't get what you sensitive dupes I
don't come from that sensitivity stuff
you know oh yeah that you get smacked in
your face when you open your mouth you
shouldn't open your mouth nothing
smacked in your face now everybody want
to rally behind you because they
sympathetic to you getting smacked you
should have never opened your mouth that
would never happen hmm
chicken of the egg type of thing right
you need to be out there you wanted to
be all click baby and put up your joint
and they who you so now's the problem
like he said who you who you you said
I'm such-and-such and listen your
contentions that's your clap bag but now
your clap bag is ah so no no
you don't give chance to hold your eye
and look for back and for other people
to hold you down no no no you acted like
this is where he will aqui answered back
he was like I am a writer for Forbes and
I'm I'm interested in this game it's
everyone else's response so he's
actually not taking it that serious baby
oh wow he made an article talking about
his experience of eating awful what's
happening right because actually I don't
for him this is what the Twitter drama
that happened between me anything and I
get that you know do do it do you I
guess the question I want to bring back
the kid with this whole the clapping
clap back thing like I guess some people
are saying I guess we still at that
point with the initial move right people
are saying that it is not he's just
reporting that nobody knows about this
game and then other people are saying yo
you kinda throw a shake so it's like
where you at with that part okay if it
doesn't say anything other than who you
know you drop the mic on your neck and
says who you know everything left so
what people that's going at you you man
because you sparked the conversation
who you think you is right my thing is
that was perfect that Bethesda did that
but there's a [ __ ] in apologize for
saying who you maybe they don't know who
you are
so there's many people on the internet
who you me personally I don't care I
don't care - somebody open their mouth
got smack and not a crying about it
oh if they're not crying about it
there's other people he's actually not
crying he mentioned specifically that
Jason Schreyer was quickly it was quick
to sort of point out that we didn't be
like yeah B these are the guys clapping
back being you know petty issue with
this thing like we put Jason's sure I
don't like this man
I was an investigator journalist you
know I disagree with a lot of his
opinions
well we go see here and act like
everything this man does is a hello to a
magnifying glass but anytime any other
journalist says people like you beat you
shop you can write do JC sure I can
literally put on Twitter I didn't like
Last of Us just say that since and
people will attack him for everything
else say everything else under the Sun
but these other journalists they can
make the most click baby title and
everyone's mad at the rage developers
for clapping back so basically what
you're saying addict is that you're cool
in basically what you're saying it s is
like for once the gaming industry clap
backing you you cool again because
they're feeling that they get abused a
lot and they they do a clap back every
now and then I'm disappointed in rage I
felt like they should was super sad I'm
with extra on why it went so left they
was actually bickering inside the joy
with the who you and don't say nothing
else but the thing is even in CDs feel
you love the game no like you understand
like oh I wanna play this game badly I'm
so tell me tell me this tell me this is
lol who are you
who even argue that's the exact quote is
that an appropriate response to somebody
having so I haven't seen enough I
haven't seen enough game I haven't seen
enough advertising on it
hahaha well you didn't say anything else
about
what about like to the people who say
that yo that rage is acting in in in
line with like the persona of the game
because if that's the case let's not go
there they would have leaned completely
into that like okay so who what
character are they playing there hahaha
who you are like what the hell is that a
lot of people said that they were they
were in in the framework the spirit of
rain in the rebellious spirit of rage
this is the end but there's the really
good news emotional out here shake would
you like to comment on this shake from
gearbox we appreciate your feedback sir
listen I get it I see where you go us
all and I do agree to some extent that
they kind of knew what they were doing
you're not saying with the clap um look
I know I'm a little I do like Tessie
you know I admit but you know maybe he's
asking a genuine question you know I'm
saying they responded you know in comedy
or whatever how you going to take it you
know the thing is to me he doesn't seem
to be bothered by it he don't seen the
news I don't know I get his feelings or
whatever whatever I think the only thing
he did say is like you know I guess I
hope I'm not blacklisted from getting a
review because I didn't want to kind of
get it together see how that's gonna
play out you don't say nothing
place since they said the who you move
me will you like actually I just want to
see like the the how arrest of his
manifest you know saying because again
you know we've we've heard that you know
but there's a in the past have
blacklisted well that's why that's why
stride jumped on the bandwagon having I
haven't gotten a game code in like five
years
[Laughter]
understand this consequences and
repercussions disagree with name down in
the book of the blacklist more cell oh
well we'll say I do
I saw a rage to stuff raced we had a
whole second on inside Xbox if I
remember to like that thing on a Soph
whatever maybe just missed Israel but
that's all I gotta curious to see how
this thing is going to develop but uh
that is all I got we gonna get into you
know you know what the biggest
disappointment or h2 is that's not on
the epic stuff salute to the famous
Lloyd addict in the extra so let's get
this get out of here man we got a role
new ILP poll this week with the latest
to stay to play episodes combining with
Sony it's announcing their non
participation at e3 how concerned are
you with how they're ending the ps4
generation the choices are a not concern
sony has 91 million reasons to be
confident heading into PS 5 be very
concerned Sony's lackluster state of
place and no III is given at Microsoft
all the ammo they need for next
generation or see I don't care Google
stadia and cloud is the true driving
force of the next generation that is the
question those are the choices like I'll
people when it goes up on Twitter
tomorrow all the Lords salute Lord
Atta quicken if I find what's going on
man finally about to go to work yeah
maybe Donuts fine
on twitter at our lord anacs ILP lock
name right now on twitter is a known me
shade some my hashtag right now on
twitter is no for Sonia so you know you
could catch me at e3 next month but you
won't catch me Saudi fan if you bring it
all oh my god we're really pin blow
really doing it okay Lord sovereign
fight today
yeah man hopefully I'll get to play
something this week we'll see we'll see
how it goes I'm about to go and uh pay
homage bend the knee to the lady that
brought me into this world go say what's
up go down oh my gosh can catch me on
Twitter loads of IOP and be excelling on
PSN and Xbox Live oh and look out check
out on the iron Lords channel on YouTube
and Lords of gaming dotnet we have two
new pieces on a game that King and I saw
at PAX East 2019 a new the distant light
from resonator games this game is a
beautiful Metroidvania and you take kind
of on the genre I'm very focused on like
improving vehicles and weapons a little
bit different than what you expect from
a normal like a Metroidvania type game
beautiful two guys worked on this game
it is an absolutely gorgeous game so
check that out we have our preview
coverage from PAX East um and we also
have a breakdown from the alpha demo
that was done by I forgot I'm no slouch
that out to all schools now exactly ow
our lords of gaming net and of course
the iron glows podcast YouTube channel
yes sir yes sir Lord King worried about
them off hey check it out he catch me
this week with one away dragon TV lord
King David aka the meatiest aka right
hanging out with almond rods
only begotten son logging David we're
gonna be and um
Bushwick radio 5 p.m. standard Eastern
Time but I want you to do how much is
going your phone I want you to download
the Bushwick radio app you can go to
your Sony I'm what you call the phone
your Apple phone or your Samsung because
those are the predominant phones we got
right now or what uh what device that
you actually can download the app from I
want you to tune in black brothers is
definitely gonna be in the building uh
see promotions all this week about it
we're gonna explain exactly what's going
forward and then we're gonna be debuting
IOP versus the world soon you're gonna
get a chance to see exactly what that's
about you're gonna see what Channel five
is about you get busy brothers you're
gonna see what that's about out there
gaming skills on deck dude's gonna
really find out what I Opie really is
about you see these Tekken dudes on this
on this panel you see this disease we
Street Fighter Samurai Shodown king of
the fighters shout out the sinister
coming through the squad is gonna be in
effect we're gonna be breaking people's
necks y'all ah yeah I want all the smoke
all right so listen king of statues your
cname alright they're the biggest base
in the building crazy base it's insane
have you a statue I got um XM studios
definitely one of my best pieces
fantastic um combat talk with the king
coming up a new statue coming up this
week this statue they kind of spoiled it
for me
so I don't I don't really want to go
into with this studio spoiled what the
next statue is this week
and we just see they're gonna be like
wow okay so we're looking for that
Wednesday no doubt you already know king
of statues everybody's looking forward
to it for say Wilhelm scream in the
building yeah man like I said I love
what you do with that it's fantastic of
course walk our needle here you already
know you find me on Twitter and all that
good stuff and last word no like this
stuff I was gonna say please check out
like I said Lords of gaming that net we
got some fantastic articles this week I
want to shout out lady panda with a
tremendous review of close to the Sun
all you bioshock lovers me to check this
game
she feels very very strongly about it
please check out her review it's up on
the channel we've also got like you said
old-school style from extreme team on a
shout them out l-boogie and I'm saying
lorrison Aldo holding down the leader of
the stream team MJ is a boss you know
I'm saying we got a lot of content out
there you guys gotta check out got I'll
play first look of a new and also check
out soft
interview with that dev like he told you
before and I'm saying it's really good
man this games got a lot of potential in
the Metro vania space and of course we
got a shout out my main Gondor is con
dogs I'm gonna tell you right now I am
an overweight overwatch hater but this
man makes this thing so exciting like I
didn't know this eSports scene was what
it was I think it was anchorman that
told me like Robert Kraft has a team and
this one team and like they are getting
it and he's making predictions shoutout
to the Dallas I can't remember the team
neighbor they're from Dallas they
saluted my boy condors Condor it's on
Lords of gaming that net every time I
see his own watch League but a little
like Altima over new out drop let me see
what's going on here this a check that
out man he's really killing it salute to
the team so love to all so the Lord
dizzying in everybody on the squad love
what we're doing so yeah that's what we
got going on and um I said a car box was
gonna have the audio up later last words
up already up there and we still got
that um roundtable reviews up there me
soft and kind box ooh so that is all I
got all in the next three weeks y'all
tuned in it's gonna be really late with
bryggen oh yeah the return in fact a the
panel's is going to be crazy
I'll give you a sneak a time to prepare
now remembers yet but I'm gonna give you
our sneak nintendo's up first so lost
each of you in there you're gonna see
it's gonna be a lot of this talk going
on like a kick face like a kick we can
miss next week King how you feel about
that you know now we go missing
we're gonna be there to put feces in a
star up to bat first that would be the
first week you're going to do a
prediction series all the greatness the
panel will be absolutely phenomenal
can't wait to let you guys know what's
happening but that's all I got everybody
happy Mother's Day
all that matrix it is so Luke we love
you we appreciate you if anybody got
anything else we are out of here peace